a cure for wellness is directed by Gore
Verbinski and stars Dane DeHaan as a
young businessman who sent to a Wellness
Center to retrieve a business associate
to take him back to New York to face
some consequences for things that he's
been involved in and when he gets to
this Wellness Center he learns that
there's some very sinister things going
on behind the scenes and he's not quite
sure if he can leave I really didn't
know what to think about this movie
going into it because the trailer was
very vague and I liked that it looked
very different and I liked that as well
it's directed by Gore Verbinski who's
made a lot of really gorgeous looking
movies he's made some stinkers in the
past but he's made the Pirates of the
Caribbean film the ring the weatherman
with Nicolas Cage which I find very
underrated personally and I also like
Dane DeHaan a lot as an actor so I was
excited to see this movie and I really
had no idea what to expect and leaving
the film I am kind of blown away
actually for a number of reasons this is
not like a masterpiece or anything but
there is definitely something to discuss
and there's something to ponder and
think about when it comes to this movie
and I've been thinking about it quite a
bit actually and I think this movie is
kind of special a cure for wellness is a
very odd movie a movie that will most
certainly make audiences cringe and a
lot of people will probably leave the
theater hating this movie because it is
so different and so off kilter from
pretty much every other film that's out
nowadays and I really have to praise
this movie for being so oddball and just
so completely bonkers that the entire
film feels like something we haven't
seen in a while although it is very
similar to a few movies in particular
the shining and shutter island' I feel
like this movie is a combination of both
of those films particularly shutter
island' obviously there's a lot going on
under the surface at this place that
Dane DeHaan uncovers as he traverses the
various corridors of this very creepy
Wellness Center and watching him uncover
this mystery is sometimes very
intriguing but there's also a lot of
exposition that is commonly thrown at us
as audience members throughout this
movie he encounters a lot of different
characters
from all different parts of this
Wellness Center and the surrounding town
and they all tell him a different
version of the same story
that's very horrific past with a fire
and some really effed up family stuff
and you start to piece things together
as the film goes along but there is a
very maddening quality to this film that
for some will actually anger them but
for me it was like a good maddening
where you just wanted answers you really
wanted the film to let you in on its
secrets and it doesn't for a very long
time this is going to bother quite a bit
of people and clearly it's bothered
quite a bit of critics as well because
the reviews for this movie aren't the
greatest this is something that confuses
me to be honest there's something about
modern film criticism that I just don't
quite understand critics are constantly
begging filmmakers to make movies that
are original they're always talking
about superhero fatigue or action movie
fatigue or the same boring dull bland
comedies over and over again give us
more original film of Hollywood angry
typing and then we get one and they
trash it I don't really get that this is
a film that requires thought it's a film
that is incredibly weird and I have to
give the studio and Gore Verbinski and
the screenwriter a lot of praise for
cooking this story up
yes it has elements of things we've seen
before it's not entirely original there
are plenty of weird institutionalized
crazy doctor movies but there's just
something so beautiful about the way he
helmed this film every shot is
immaculate I mean the framing is almost
perfect the editing is astoundingly good
between this film and splits
we've already had two amazing looking
movies this year cure for wellness is
not a great film because there are
certain things holding it back in my
opinion from being great for one it's
extremely long it's two hours in like 36
minutes and sometimes it feels like that
because it is a lot of exploration it's
a lot of weird looks and I don't know
what's going on with my life and you
know seems like that and so it does kind
of drag also I can see why
anyone would hate this movie because it
gets so weird and strange and just
incredibly insane towards the third act
that I kind of respected it but I can
see other people being like this is just
dumb and silly and over-the-top and I
liked it until this happened
I don't know I just kind of appreciated
the fact that this movie had the balls
to go as different as it did and it gave
me something to think about it gave me a
movie that wasn't just the same old same
old in the middle of this
january/february season Dane DeHaan is
excellent in this movie it's a very good
performance jason isaacs as an
incredibly creepy doctor is also very
very good as I already stated the
directing and editing is amazing like
really good this is a fantastic looking
and sounding movie the sound design
there are so many sequences where he is
on these crutches going through these
very quiet empty hallways and just the
sounds of the crutches
became unnerving after a while there's a
lot of very disturbing imagery I loved
the ring tape which Gore Verbinski is
very good at creating a lot of cerebral
surreal images that just kind of haunt
your brain all in all I think the film
makes sense when I sat down and really
thought about it I liked it a lot
actually I think this is a movie
destined to be one of those cult classic
films that a lot of people see hates and
then small circles start to analyze it
and look into the meaning of things and
then they do know they make big two-hour
analysis videos like I've done in the
past and then somehow someway eventually
20 years from now there's revival
screenings of it I think this movie is
kind of special and I think critics are
missing the boat on this one it's weird
it's different it's strange it requires
a lot of thought which is something that
modern audience members and
unfortunately some critics don't like
anymore I'm going to give a cure for
wellness of B+
I would recommend seeing this movie on
one specific reason alone it's an
original movie it's not a sequel it's
not a reboot it's not a prequel it's not
a remake it's not a retelling it's not
an adaptation it's not a recoil boot
it's just a movie that was made up and
they put it in theaters and it's so
weird and different and long and they
put it in theaters so go see it go
support original films guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]